[Musique]
Taron Je veux que tu ailles bien Je veux que
tu aies une belle vie Je t'aime mais nous
ne voyons pas comment tu peux vivre sur
ce toit
si nous allons fondamentalement aller à
l'encontre de nos croyances Tara dis-moi
la vérité c'est tout ce que je pense des hommes je
ne sais pas pourquoi je suis tellement désolée que tes parents
t'aient inscrit à un programme pour te soigner
mais Karen tu es un adolescent parfaitement normal en
très bonne santé ils vont
faire des choses pour toi toi  je veux dire
bienvenue au programme de refuge de vous
ne pouvez pas naître homosexuel c'est
vivant c'est votre choix
pas de faux jusqu'à ce que vous le fassiez devenir l'
homme que vous n'êtes pas sauvez-vous d'accord Dieu
ne vous aimera pas comme vous êtes
est ce quoi  tu veux
qui va commencer ce démon j'ai du
mal je vais te donner
des conseils dis leur ce qu'ils
veulent entendre
jouer le rôle sauf si tu penses vraiment que
tu peux changer ou même vouloir ce que
tu traverses en ce moment  C'est juste un moment
inconnu ouais un moment j'aime Dieu et
j'aime moi  ton fils pour ton père c'est un
peu plus compliqué nous n'avons pas
fini je le suis parce que tu n'écouteras pas
ton père est assis ici en train de dire comment
tu le détestes je ne vais pas faire semblant je
déteste mon père je ne déteste pas mon père
alors  d'où vient toute cette colère
parce que tu me mets en colère
maintenant ils disent que parfois tu dois blesser un
enfant pour l'aider mais une mère
sait quand quelque chose
ne va pas je ne veux plus faire semblant j'ai dû
me demander  et Dieu si je suis prêt à
te perdre
tu ne
vas pas te délivrer
[Musique]